-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden reportedly
told aides in a recent meeting
that they need
to make progress
in reversing his decline
in poll numbers.
And hopefully Jill and Travis
will understand.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
President Biden frequently
tells aides and friends
in private conversations
that he feels
"so much younger than his age."
And I'm sure he does,
but it doesn't inspire
a ton of confidence
when you walk around
saying, "Man, I feel 73!"
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
is trying to improve
President Biden's diet,
or at least trying to get him
to add another food group.
[ Laughter ]
The two Georgia
election workers
who won $148 million verdict
on Friday against Rudy Giuliani
filed another lawsuit yesterday
after Giuliani
continued making false
statements about them.
Only Rudy could lose
a $148 million lawsuit
and say, [As Giuliani]
"Alright, double or nothing!
[ Laughter ]
Put it all on blue!"
A new poll found
that 3 in 10 people
who voted for
former President Trump
want a president who is
willing to break rules and laws.
And in an act of desperation,
Biden ripped the tags
off his mattress.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell
has an approval rating
of just 6%.
Incidentally, 6% is also
what he's buffering at.
[ Laughter ]
In a new campaign ad,
Republican presidential hopeful
Nikki Haley
says that President Biden
is too old
and calls for term limits
and mental competency tests,
which is why we need young,
sharp politicians
like New York Mayor Eric Adams.
-When you look at
the totality of the year,
if you had to describe it,
and it's tough to do,
in one word,
what would that word be,
and tell me why?
-New York.
This is a place
where every day you wake up,
you could experience
everything from a plane
crashing into our Trade Center
to a person
who's celebrating
a new business that's opened.
This is a very,
very complicated city,
and that's why it's
the greatest city on the globe.
[ Laughter ]
-Honey!
I don't want to go
to New York anymore!
[ Laughter ]
Nikki Haley is right.
Term limits might be
a good idea.
How about half a term?
Is that too soon?
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
over the weekend
met Jacob Chansley,
the so-called QAnon shaman,
in what is being called
Hallmark's
worst Christmas movie ever.
[ Laughter ]
The Greek yogurt company Chobani
has acquired the coffee chain
La Colombe for $900 million
because they are dedicated
to making sure
their customers [laughs]
never leave the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
You know, finally, a man
in Alabama
who was arrested recently
for alleged possession
of a controlled substance
had a parrot on his shoulder
and told officers he was high
on mushrooms.
Said the parrot, [as parrot]
"Don't forget the crack!"
[ Laughter ]
Not good. Not good. We --
In rehearsal, I nail--
Oh, the parrot was good earlier.
[ Laughter ]
I shouldn't have burned it when
we were doing cards earlier.
[ Imitating parrot ]
No, I still don't have it.
Maybe later in the show,
we'll get back to it.
That was a monologue, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We've got a great show
for you tonight.
She is an Emmy-winning
writer, comedian, and actress
from my home state
of New Hampshire --
hometown even, Bedford.
You can see her in the
critically acclaimed "Maestro,"
which is in theaters now
and on Netflix tomorrow.
The wonderful,
one of our favorites,
Sarah Silverman,
is back on the show, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you know her
from "Russian Doll"
and "The Morning Show."
She stars in one of my favorite
movies of the year,
"Past Lives."
It's beautiful, it's wonderful.
Greta Lee will also be
joining us,
and he is
a James Beard Award-winning chef
whose book "Mi Cocina:
Recipes and Rapture
From My Kitchen in Mexico"
is available now.
We will be cooking with chef
Rick Martinez, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, you guys, my brother and I,
we have a podcast called
"Family Trips."
We talk to people
about the family trips
they took when they were kids.
We have a great episode
this week with Nate Bargatze.
He is fantastic, as always.
Do check that out.
Also, if you are in Las Vegas
on New Year's Eve
and you are looking
for something to do,
me and my friend John Oliver
will be at the Colosseum
at Caesars Palace in Las Vegas.
Come check us out.
We are so happy.
We're so excited
to do that show
and then as soon as it's over,
go right to bed.
[ Laughter ]
That is how John and I party,
you guys.
Uh, moving on, this morning
I was practicing
my hockey stops in the
Rockefeller ice skating rink
when I overheard
a family of Austrian tourists
discussing a new breed
of migrating tree frogs, and --
[ Sniffing ]
Wait. I am so sorry.
I could be wrong here,
but I think I smell some smoke
and that can only mean
one thing.
It's time for "Ya Burnt."
♪♪
Welcome to the Burn Zone.
We got a lot of topics to sizzle
through and not a lot of time.
Over here is the burner.
Let's turn on the gas
and load her up.
Whoo! Feliz navidadi!
[ Laughter ]
First up, ornaments.
Hey, ornaments, if I wanted
to see dusty red balls
hanging under a shaggy thicket,
I'd go to the YMCA
on a weekday afternoon.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. We're starting
with a testicles joke.
That's how we do Christmas
in Burn Town.
Hey, ornaments,
you know what I don't want
dangling precariously off a twig
in a house
with three kids and a dog?
Something that shatters.
You want me to hang orbs
of the world's thinnest glass
at toddler eye level?
Why don't I just
paint the word "noel"
on some hand grenades instead?
Also, it's bad enough
we just ripped
a healthy young tree
out of the ground.
Now we got to desecrate
the corpse
by dressing it up like
a stripper at a bachelor party?
It's bringing holiday cheer,
not starting an OnlyFans.
And not only are the
store-bought ornaments bad,
now I got to pretend
to be impressed
by those homemade monstrosities
my kids bring home from school?
Wow, you made this
with just popsicle sticks
and all the glue?
I...never would have guessed.
Let's hang it in the back
facing the wall
with all your
other masterpieces.
Side burn my infant daughter.
-Side burn!
-It's okay.
She won't see this.
She only ever
watches the monologue.
Hey, ornaments!
Time to join the Yule log
in the fireplace, ya burnt!
Advent calendars.
Ah, advent calendars --
the least efficient way
to distribute candy
since Halloween brought us
door-to-door begging.
[ Laughter ]
If you want gifts
before Christmas that badly,
do what I did and marry
into a Jewish family.
-Marrying up!
-The great thing
about advent calendars
is when you give a kid
one piece of candy,
they're totally satisfied
for the next 24 hours.
You ever tried to give a kid
one piece of candy?
You know what would work better?
24 advent calendars.
And if you're worried
about the candy not being fresh
by the time you open it
on December 24th,
remember they packed it
in April.
Here's an idea,
advent calendars --
make one of you
that counts down the days
to the 2024 election so I really
know when to beg Jesus for help.
-Fill it with Xanax!
-Advent calendars,
did I accidentally
hang you over a menorah?
'Cause ya burnt!
Mulled wine.
Finally, an answer
to the question
what if potpourri
could get you [bleep] up?
[ Laughter ]
Not to play sommelier here,
but I'm pretty sure red wine
is meant to be served at room
temp or slightly chilled,
not scalding hot
and full of mulch.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I don't know
if it technically counts
as a secret family recipe
if you throw in
a pinch of every single spice
in your pantry.
But at least we finally polished
off the jar of cloves Aunt Judy
gave us when Bush
was still in office.
-Mission accomplished!
-Hey, mulled wine,
mull this over. Ya burnt.
Caroling.
Oh, good.
Sober karaoke with strangers
is available for delivery.
[ Laughter ]
And they do all of the songs
I already have on Spotify,
but worse?
Sign me up.
This is the real
"Nightmare Before Christmas."
Nothing more disappointing than
thinking your Thai food is here,
then opening the door to find
your 10 weirdest neighbors
informing you
Christ the Savior is born.
I want my Pad Thai,
God damn it!
You're like if Jehovah's
Witnesses went to theatre camp.
Hey, carolers, how about
you do "Silent Night"?
Not the song, the activity.
So let me make something clear.
I will wish you
a merry Christmas,
but I will not be bringing you
some figgy pudding.
I don't have
any figgy pudding.
I don't know where
to get figgy pudding.
If Whole Foods hasn't figured
out figgy pudding,
then no one has figgy pudding,
you absolute psychopaths.
Hey, carolers, go
fa-la-la-la-la-ck yourself.
Ya burnt!
Those commercials
where people get a car
for Christmas with a big bow
on it, let's cut the [bleep].
It's never happened.
I don't even believe that people
are giving each other cars
for Christmas, let alone ones
with big bows on them.
And if they did,
it would never look like that.
Imagine your dad
in the driveway on Christmas Eve
trying to curl a ribbon
with a giant pair of scissors,
cursing so loud
the whole neighborhood can hear.
He's not keeping this a secret.
And let me get this straight --
you're asking about a --
you're asking a fictional
demigod from the North Pole
to bring you a free vehicle,
and you opted for a Kia Sorento?
You don't give a Kia with a bow.
You give it with a gift receipt.
Hey, giant car bows, this going
to be a December to remember,
because ya burnt!
Hey, elves! Elves!
Hey, elves!
Elves!!
I'm just going to say it --
you're all getting played.
You've been working
200-hour work weeks
with no vacation for, what,
three, four centuries?
You do all the work
and the credit
goes to the jolly fat man?
You're either going
to have to unionize
or take out Santa,
'cause at some point
enough is enough.
And look, elves,
we're pro-labor here.
We support you,
but I do not
and I will never support
Elf on the Shelf.
All your friends
are doing hard work,
and you're spying on children?
You a creep, bro.
I feel like
they give pervy elves that job
the same way priests
get moved to a new parish.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
[ Blows ]
Elves, time to go jump in the
snow, because ya burnt!
Malls,
the Amazon.com of the '80s.
Have you been
to a mall recently, kids?
No? Well, guess what.
You're missing out!
Gen Z, get off TikTok
and go to the mall.
And, malls, you make your own
algorithm, man.
Check these out!
Did I get these at a store?
No, bro. I got them at a hut!
[ Laughter ]
I didn't even
have to pay for them.
I waited for 15 minutes to see
if anybody worked there,
and when nobody showed up,
I just took them.
Then I waded around
in the fountain,
gathered enough quarters to play
"Mortal Kombat" at the arcade
until my fingers bled.
Sounds like a full day, right?
Wrong!
Because then I swooped
over to Lids
and copped this sweet hat.
Did a pit stop at Auntie Anne's
for a month's worth of carbs.
And, look, I know
you can get pornography
at the tip of your fingers,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
but you can also pop
into Spencer's Gifts,
drop by the poster rack,
and have
a whole-ass relationship
with a picture
of a bikini-clad model
sprawled out on the hood
of a Porsche!
That's living,
and that's why malls
are this weeks unburnable.
[ Angelic music plays ]
Ascend to safety!
[ Applause ]
How many days ago
did we get these pretzels?
[ Laughter ]
Wreaths!
Oh, look,
it's the Christmas tree's
crackhead cousin
outside your door again.
Want to show people
you have a holiday spirit,
but don't want to put
any effort to it?
Try a wreath.
Nothing like paying 50 bucks for
the scraps from the real trees.
It's like going to a pizza place
and ordering just crust.
What's the point
of a wreath anyway?
Is it a warning
to the other trees?
The only good news
is I can sweep up all that crap
that falls off my wreath
and use it to make mulled wine.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, wreaths,
I'm rethinking you,
and I decided ya burnt.
The Christmas goose.
Oh, no!
Oh, no! The goose!
I completely forgot
to take out the goose.
Oh, no! My beautiful 12-pound
goose that I fattened all year.
Oh, no. Oh, please be okay,
the goose.
Please be okay!
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh, why didn't this part burn?
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughs ]
I just realized
I'm still wearing the hat.
[ Laughter ]
Goose, ya burnt!
Up next, Tiny Tim.
Listen up,
you Cratchit-y little bitch.
[ Buzzer ]
Oh, that buzzer means
we're out of time.
Looks like I'll have to
burn your Dickens off
next one out.
This is has been "Ya Burnt."
We'll be right back
with Sarah Silverman.